at the sabre airfield russian helicopter
gunships take to the air nearby dozens
of russian trucks leave the training
grounds
armored personnel carriers are
transported towards the border with
ukraine the south of belarus looks like
a russian military zone
this abandoned airfield in saborovka
near the city of hommel is one of the 12
areas where russia and belarus are
conducting joint drills known as allied
resolve
visitors are not allowed in but local
people tell us the airstrip is in bad
shape and has recently been used for
sports competitions
footage released by the russian ministry
of defense shows state-of-the-art
military equipment in action near the
border between belarus and ukraine and
nato
several divisions of s-400 missile
defense systems and dozens of sukhoi
fighter jets are taking part in the
exercises
in response to questions from the baltic
states belarus has confirmed that
russian forces are also active outside
the scope of these drills
some military units and subunits from
the eastern military district of the
armed forces of the russian federation
are performing tasks outside the
framework of the exercise
they have been deployed and are
performing practical measures to guard a
southern state border where there are no
opportunities to reinforce it using
border patrol units of the republic of
belarus there are a lot of questions
about the exact size and the real
purpose of these exercises happening
around 20 kilometers from the border
with ukraine for sure russian forces are
a lot more active this close to the
ukrainian capital kiev a lot more active
than they've had been since the end of
the cold war but for many here it's hard
to believe that war is imminent
after a government crackdown on
protesters in 2020 independent media was
shot down in belarus and its embattled
leader alexander lukashenka turned to
russian president vladimir putin for
help
it won't happen we were told it won't
happen first they said there will be a
war but i watched the news and
lukashenka said there won't be a war
they brought some tanks and trucks we
thought there was a war but it turned
out it was a test of military readiness
vladimir katsura the leader of an
opposition party in holmel is not that
optimistic he says many people in
belarus would like to demonstrate
against a possible war but are too
scared to do so
i'm personally very worried i have
family i don't want war like most
belarusians but as i see the
developments going on so far under the
disguise of military exercises it
naturally makes me very worried
on this main road to ukraine's capital
kiev buses and trucks are still crossing
the border but kiev is only 200
kilometers away and russia's show of
military force nearby is making people
in ukraine and western powers very
nervous staff farsan al jazeera in
subrovka belarus